hey everyone bandit here the other day i
made a community post right here on
youtube about fam theories that you may
have that none of the zelda theorists
have covered yet and i made a video
about it and turns out it was actually a
really good idea that most of you really
enjoyed watching so thank you so much
for the positive reactions and if you
haven't gotten a chance to check it out
yet i'll leave a link in the description
below but i wanted to bring attention to
one comment that i saw in particular
that was just too big to not receive a
dedicated video it's a breath of the
wild sequel theory from a user named
jaden everett now the theory that he
brings up is actually what i'm going to
cover in this video so i won't show the
comment on the screen in its entirety at
this time but please feel free to head
over to the comments of the community
post and leave a like on jaden's comment
to show him some support after the video
between reading jaden's comment and
talking it over with one of my good
friends and discord server moderators
named lonline historian who had a lot to
bring to the table i think this theory
has some very decent believability and
it's all about ganondorf and the master
sword but probably not like what you're
thinking see pretty much everyone at
this point has pointed out that as of
the second breath of the wild sequel
trailer link has been shown doing
several new things like falling through
the sky or shooting flames out of a
shield attachment on his
shield or having malice grapple onto his
arm and as i'm sure you all remember
that last nasty malice one was the only
time in the second trailer that link was
shown with the master sword all of his
appearances afterwards be it in hyrule
or skyrule are master sword less and
sure it could just be a case of link
using other weapons as the master sword
could just be chilling in his inventory
you know recharging but i think it's
more deliberate than that see ever since
the first trailer to the sequel when
zelda and link were exploring that
mysterious dank cave link has been shown
with the master sword deliberately like
in every shot and then similarly the
first thing you see in the new trailer
is again link with the master sword
deliberately but then never again in
every other shot in the trailer to me as
i said in a previous video that i did
with mr celtic who's actually a really
cool guy by the way i think this implies
that link loses the master sword and i
think it happens when ling's arm gets
grappled onto and corrupted by that
malice which we can see has literally
changed his arm's appearance for the
remainder of the trailer well either
that or the green power that grapples
onto it in the first trailer but that's
besides the point clearly link survives
this encounter and i'm sure that's what
the events of the game are largely going
to cover but the thing is if the master
sword isn't with our blonde hero for the
events of the game it must still be
chilling back in that cave with
ganondorf who we can't forget was shown
to be standing with his arms stretched
outwards almost triumphantly in the new
trailer as if things were all going
according to plan the question is what
plan if ganondorf did take the master
sword from link what exactly is he going
to do with it could he even do anything
to it great questions i'm so glad you
all asked because i can't answer any of
them for sure but we can speculate let
us now rewind from the latest game in
the timeline breath of the wild all the
way back to the first game in the
timeline skyward sword back to the birth
of the master sword to quickly recap
what happens to the master sword in the
game basically it starts out as a highly
afforded blade known as the goddess
sword and then gets tempered by the
flames of din faror and nehru and then
blessed by the mortal incarnation of
hylia also known as zelda in order to
transform fully into the true master
sword complete with the power to repel
evil actually it's more like the power
to contain evil see link takes up the
sword and at the end of the game after
girihim pulls some time shenanigans and
takes their fight into the past ends up
fighting the big bad og demon king
himself demise not only does link fight
demise he kills him well kind of that's
actually kind of questionable here
because demise doesn't go up dead like a
normal person he instead does this sort
of thanos snap dissolve into thin air
thing and gets absorbed into the master
sword directly the spirit that resides
in the sword that goes by a name that i
refuse to pronounce at this time even
confirms this and states that she has
confirmed the eradication of the demon
king whose residual consciousness has
been absorbed into the master sword and
is now sealed away but notice they never
once state that demise has died actually
he wasn't completely gone which i think
is key here impa even confirms this
later on and says that the last remnants
of demise are slowly decaying within the
master sword and she even elects to stay
behind and watch over the sword because
of this out of fear that he might
actually break out of his seal since he
still exists so here's the next question
to ask if the biggest and baddest dude
ever known in the history of the zelda
universe is not actually dead yet and is
still alive within the master sword
might this have some sort of impact on
the sword well yes it just might
actually and this is where jaden's
comment really starts to shine see he
theorizes that demise's intense demonic
essence even though it was in a weakened
state was still very much so alive and
was actually causing the master sword in
turn to weaken this is why skyward
strikes are no longer a thing following
demise's entry into the sword at the end
of skyrid's sword and it's also why the
master sword appears to now have a
tendency of slowly fading in potency
over time having to routinely be
re-empowered back to its original state
in games like the wind waker or a link
between worlds or most recently breath
of the wild it is a bit strange that the
perfect seemingly omnipotent blade of
evil's bane created by hylia herself
would continually tend to lose its touch
wouldn't you say but i know what you're
thinking what does all of this have to
do with ganondorf in the trailer for
breath of the wild too hold your loft
wings i'm getting there so we talked
about the master sword containing the
very essence of the original most
powerful of all demon kings right and
we've talked about how demise's essence
is probably still living within the
sword as proven by its slow drain over
time now let's bring it back to this
scene in the cave of the breath of the
wild sequel haven't you felt that
something's off here i know something
evil is about to happen but haven't you
felt that something very very wrong is
about to happen maybe it's something
about the music or the fact that
everything is so different but i can't
help feeling that something may happen
so terrifying that it may shatter all of
our expectations and even the very
foundations of the zelda metanarrative
as we know it after the incarnation of
his malice the dark beast ganon was
ultimately defeated and his plan stopped
for what must be the hundredth or
thousandth time what if ganondorf
decided he's had enough and that he's
out to change the cycle forever what if
ganondorf knows that demise exists
within the blade and he took it from
link in order to release the essence of
the original demon king from within the
sword in order to fuse with his own
power and create a darkness the likes of
which the world has never seen this is
what jaden's comment was about i've
theorized before that the master swords
breaking may be necessary to finally
stop the cycling curse of the demon
tribe which is as good a theory as any
other but that was implying that
breaking it would destroy demise what if
instead breaking it would release him of
course ganondorf being able to break the
master sword is something that you
wouldn't think is possible at first but
what if he doesn't have to break it what
if instead he could somehow coax the
essence of demise out of the blade by
using dark magic all he really needed
was to separate the blade from link and
remove zelda from the picture both of
which he's done will ganondorf terrorize
hyrule worse than ever before with the
full power of demise at his disposal who
knows after all it's just a neat theory
from a couple of awesome zelda theorists
named jaden everett and law online
historian personally i look forward to
finding out in 2022 if nintendo keeps to
that release schedule
but until then what did you guys think
about this theory let me know in the
comments below and let me know if you
have a theory that you'd like me to
check out and potentially cover as well
also to all of you listening to my voice
right now thank you thank you so much
for watching and if i could ask
something of you real quick would you be
so kind as to leave a like on this video
if you liked this video and subscribe to
the channel if you haven't already in
order to stick around for much more
nintendo content to come it takes two
seconds and you can always unsubscribe
later also huge thanks to my bandit crew
who make my day every single day if you
watching are interested in helping these
videos come to life and helping an
internet weirdo like myself buy some
chicken nuggies for my rumbling tummies
please feel free to check out that join
button located below any of my videos or
the patreon and merch pages in the
description below also down there are
the links to my social media pages so
come on over and follow me on twitter or
instagram for some colorful insights
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is maskington abandoned
looking forward to seeing you in the
next one and signing out
[Music]
you